leute die spiele heute die bullshit
die kämpfe werden video von andere schon
mal gemacht das ganze funktioniert so
man gibt einen überbegriff das sind zb
staubsauger marken und daraus jedoch
überlegen was ich denke wie viele davon
drei kennt sagt er
da ist nichts dran und der wird entweder
sagen kind kennt vier aussteiger oder
sachschäden da muss eine andere die drei
nennen 10-20 von er hat jeweils zwei
sekunden und einer das spiel führen
man kann auslöser für den jeweiligen
verlierer der werden kann oder abbrechen
weil spieler kann eine kleine
künstlichkeit vorbei und war doch noch
geht
dann könnte auch nach willkommen
die erste kategorie süßigkeiten machen
oder so arten wie schon bei welcher
versagen
durch und wird bei 80 kalorien 98 4 32
meter bounty maribor trolley bonbons
popcorn
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich werde mich definitiv ich sage
fußballsimulationen 1 2332 aber eins
muss man sagen es ist schon nicht
schlecht wäre die kurve vor verraten
das wird noch lange nicht an kuchen so
oft man will sollte die verfassung
[Gelächter]
muss die nachricht perfekt werden
erinnerungen für alle tage in new york
ist nicht klar wenn ich dich dann 485
auf weil ich würde die fünf high end
youtube marken aufzählen kann
aber ich bin ich schon wieder einen
supercup war auch brennt immer rock
liegt voll im trend
noch mehr als wert denn dass sie sind
mein brauchten
okay was kostet für die primaten ja dann
sagt verfassen
1969 9 69 sekunden gebraucht
gerne mal